Here's how the game works.
If a contestant can answer 6 questions,
from 6 feet away in 60 seconds,
they'll win $600.
And if they answer less than six questions correctly,
they'll still go home with a fun prize.
A six pack!
So, it's win-win!
Okay everybody, our first contestant is Meredith.
Hi Meredith!
You're ready to play?
Yes.
All right, Alex, start the timer.
Okay, what did Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel
just name their second child,
Phineas or Linus?
Uh,
Linus.
Nope.
How many elements are there in a periodic table?
118 or 88?
God, okay, okay, okay, I knew this.
Um, what are the choices?
118 or 88?
118.
Yes.
Which one of these is not an Olympic sport?
Badminton or dodge ball?
Badminton.
No.
Who was the first vice president of the United States,
John Adams or James Madison?
Oh, I know this, I know this, I know this,
um, it is...
What were the choices again?
John Adams or James Madison?
James Madison.
Nope, John Adams.
What breed of dog is Scooby-Doo?
Saint Bernard or Great Dane?
Great Dane.
Yes!
Okay,
and which one of these temperatures can water freeze?
32 degrees Fahrenheit or-
Celsius or Fahrenheit?
Fahrenheit.
Yes!
No!
Okay, how many did you get right?
Uh, gosh darn it Meredith.
Yeah!
Woo!
Okay everybody,
it's our second contestant.
Its Christina!
(applause)
All right, here we go, Christina.
All right, ready?
Set, go.
Okay.
Anteaters do not have which of the following?
Teeth or a sense of smell?
Uh, no they don't, okay a sense of smell?
No, it's teeth.
Which solo artist holds the record
for most number one singles?
Mariah Carey or Madonna?
Must be Madonna.
It's Mariah Carey, shockingly enough.
Which is the only NFL team that has their logo
only on one side of their helmets?
The New Orleans Saints or the Pittsburgh Steelers?
I'm going to go ahead and say The Saints.
Nope.
Ah!
Which state I sin between Ohio and Illinois?
Iowa or Indiana?
Um, it's got to be Indiana?
Yes!
Woo hoo!
How many keys does a piano have?
77 or 88?
78?
88.
Gosh, darn it!
One more, one more.
For which film did Steven Spielberg
win a best picture Oscar?
E.T. or Schindler's List?
Must be E.T.
No! It's Schindler's List!
Come on!
Okay,
how many oceans are there in the world?
Five or seven?
Seven.
Five!
(Christine screams)
All right.
Oh yeah, you get the token crappy six pack.
Oh six pack, whomp, whomp, thank you Drew!
Oh, I'm sorry Christina.
Okay, what is your name?
Zara.
Zara! Beautiful!
Thank you.
And the best store
(Zara laughs)
Oh my gosh, Zara, okay ready?
I'm really excited, yeah I'm ready.
Oh God, I hope you get easier questions.
I hope so too.
All right!
Are you ready, Alex?
Start the time.
All right,
where do cats sweat?
Through their paws or whiskers?
6- Whiskers.
No, paws.
Which member of One Direction
was the first to leave the group?
Zayn Malik or Harry Styles?
Harry Styles.
No, it was Zayn Malik!
What country is directly north of Hungary?
Switzerland or Slovakia?
Slovakia
Thank God!
Yes!
Which of these is a prime number, three or 33?
Three!
Yes!
In golf, what is it called when a player
makes one-over par on an individual hole?
A birdie or a bogey?
Over par, one over par individual-
Lets face it, you're just gonna guess here.
A birdie!
It's a bogey.
How long is the The Great Wall of China?
13,171 miles
or 17,131 miles?
Let's go with 17,000 whatever.
It's 13!
Which astrological sign is represented by the scales,
Pisces or Libra?
Libra, that's my sign
Yes! Thank God!
I'm a Pisces!
Okay!
What is Prince Harry's wife's name?
Megan Markle or Kate Middleton?
Prince Harry?
Yes.
Megan Markle!
Yes! Of course it is!
(buzzer)
How many did we get?
Argh!
Gosh darn it!
This game is impossible!
Thank you so much Drew!
Sorry!
I'm sorry!
I'm going to really enjoy this six pack.
These are Flower Beauty,
I put a lip and a cheek in there for you.
Oh my God!
I don't know what, thank you!
Just buy yourself some cocktails.
Christina, Meredith
and Zara,
thank you so much for your time today.
I'm really appreciative.
(upbeat music)